[Music]
now the
clearly publicity shy minor royals the
duke and duchess of sussex
opened up to real royalty this week
queen opera
of all the americas and beyond only
about
another 100 million or so around the
globe got to watch and listen to
so the couple must have been pleased
that their wish for privacy was being
respected
much of the content was absurdly trivial
like tears
over a floral dress but when the
interview touched on race and mental
health matters it was
incendiary enough to provoke an
onslaught on the royal family
from around the globe in this week's
spectator our deputy editor freddie gray
writes that harry and megan
have set up their rival royal house in
california
and he joins the show now together with
spectator columnist rod little
who muses on the american individualism
that explains so much of megan
marco well welcome to you both freddie
what do you mean by a rival royal family
across the pond
well i think harry and megan have uh
established themselves as a a house of
woke really and
i mean i think we tend to overuse the
word woke it's a bit of a sort of
catch-all
uh but it is quite useful in summing up
uh their worldview
and their worldview is very much
oriented around celebrity
and sort of therapy really because if
you if you watch the oprah interview
it's like a long
counseling session um and this is
actually very potent in the media
because people love talking about their
feelings
and i think where harry and megan got
this idea from
was the heads together campaign which
was something the younger royals
launched
in 2017 uh when they decided that mental
health they wanted to do a big drive on
mental health
and a lot of sort of royal people royal
suckups pr operatives
got very excited about this idea that
the younger royals could rebrand the
monarchy by talking about their feelings
um and how much they suffered um but i
think other people within the royal
family realized this was quite a bad
idea and that people don't want
to hear uh royals gassing on about their
feelings
and so william and kate sort of pulled
back a bit from that
i think but harry and megan it came to
them very naturally and
and they couldn't stop themselves so
they they have become this sort of
rival house of therapeutic woke culture
and rod you can see that in some of the
language that both
meghan markle and uh oprah winfrey
use because apparently what now matters
is that people have their own truth
that what i think is truth is truth even
if it isn't true
yes and i i think i think it it lies at
the
very center of this this problem we have
with with megan and to degree harry i
mean
harry matters so much less in a way
because the driving force
seems to be megan um that it's
right from the beginning our antipathy
towards the woman
if there was any in the press and there
was
uh seemed to be not because she was a
mixed race
i don't know anyone who who objected to
the color of her skin
but because she was an american and a
particular kind of american who cleaves
to those values
which some americans do and you see that
in the narcissism
in the the relentless self-examination
and self-obsession
and i think it's the consequence i mean
i suppose it's a pretentious argument
but it's
it i think it evolves from america's
uh primacy of the individual over the
communitarian
in that you can if you're an individual
have your own truth
and you can if you're an indie
individual have your own concept of
duty which is what she said and her
concept of duty
didn't involve doing as she was told and
performing a service for a country
uh it involved scampering off to
california i doing what she likes
it's it's a very interesting view of the
world and i i think a lot of the
antipathy does come down to the fact
that it really is a culture clash not
not a not a racist culture just that
usual culture clash between
uh the us and britain and don't forget
that that individualism
uh we have imported to a huge degree
from america
uh and that individualism is is also
part of identity politics which of
course
both harry and megan cleave to again uh
that that people can be whatever they
wish to be
uh and that uh an individual what an
individual
feels is more important than what
actually the truth is so i think an
awful lot of that plays into it
it is interesting rod though the way the
whole interview was framed and
particularly what megan marco
was saying with harry basically just
having a walk-on part
it's very much the way a lot of woke
dialogue goes there so if i feel
i've been victimized i am victimized
just enough to to feel it that
let's talk about me uh there's a
self-obsession here
but it's i'm the one that matters
particularly since i'm
a victim and i need to justify uh
myself that my truth matters
more than whatever the factual situation
is that
i saw this uh being used by the
the weatherman on good morning britain
against piers morgan
it it may not be true but it's her lived
experiences this is
whatever this new phrase is and lived
experience
if that's what you think it is trump's
facts
yeah what's an unlived experience i've
often wondered that
um i mean you're absolutely right and
and and
it shines through in everything she says
uh but but it's also clearly the problem
that there was with the royal family now
i agree with freddie i think most
americans don't give a monkeys about our
royal family i'm sure that's right
but it's that individualism i am now
part of this i think she thought
she was she was signing up to a kind of
rather gilded celebrity dumb which was a
little bit like hollywood
where she could express herself and put
forward her very often inane beliefs
about the world
with with with with no restraint and
then as soon as she found out that it
was different to that that there was
something involving
service and discipline and dignity
involved
she scampered off to as i say to
california or canada as she
put it originally we we all knew they
weren't going to be staying in
moose jaw canada for very long uh and
indeed
they soon went to santa barbara so i i
think that's exactly it
it is exactly that woke culture which we
have imported
largely from the usa and it devolves
always to the individual
and there is no communitarian sense
about it there's no sense about
about whether it's good for the royal
family or not or whether it's good for
great britain or not it's about whether
it's good for me or not
and that that's that's the great
difficulty and somehow
harry who it's a terrible thing to say
may not necessarily be the brightest lad
in the world
uh has been kind of dragged along with
this and
i i still i still kind of uh
cleaved to the idea that maybe in a few
years time he will regret what he's done
uh but but uh certainly doesn't seem to
at the moment
it's still not clear to me freddie
whether she
was properly briefed or it was properly
explained what being
uh a royal meant particularly one
at that time they would be they were
quite pretty senior roles
indeed it was meant to be uh they were
to be the beatles who were the four
it was will and kate harry and megan
that was she properly briefed um
or wasn't she and even if she was
properly briefed did she just think i
can change this because
it does seem to me that she didn't
understand two things
being a royal is different from being a
celebrity uh
and you have to behave differently i
mean when when did will i see the queen
jump on a billionaire's
private jet uh it's just not or
be in conspicuous consumption is just
not what they do
plus you can't really lecture people
about global warming or inequality or
all
the rest of it that again is i mean
charles has got into trouble for
straying into some areas but it's really
not what you can do you cannot have
strong opinions
and you can't behave as if you are a
hollywood celebrity
and what i'm not sure is whether that
was spelled out to her
or whether she didn't realize it or that
it was spelled out and she said
yeah but that's yesterday i can be a
celebrity
hollywood style and i can have opinions
on whatever i want
silence remember she said she was
silenced what do you think
well i mean i'm not sure i found it a
bit disingenuous when she started
talking about
how you know she had no idea she didn't
really she hadn't even googled harry she
didn't really know
anything about this family that she was
marrying
i didn't quite believe that and i also
think that
it shouldn't really need to be spelled
out to you and i'm sure she
i'm sure she was told uh what the
protocol was on various things and then
she just decided
that that wasn't for her i thought it
was very interesting that both
megan and harry went to such lengths to
praise the queen
and i think that's because they they
don't understand much but they do
understand the power of brands and sort
of global brands
and in some sense they understand that
the reason the queen is so popular
is because she hasn't gassed on about
her feelings she's kept her mental
health
private and that's something they're
unable to do and what they can't
quite grasp is that they can't be royals
in the
in the royal sense in the traditional
sense and be these celebrities
who gas on about their feelings it's
just not sustainable for a monarchy in
the british sense
was there not though freddie something a
bit disingenuous you
you you praise the queen yeah we know
why they're doing that uh
whatever the view of the royal family
the queen's global image is uh
without parallel uh
better than ever i would say in in all
the years she's been on the throne
so you can hardly be seen to trash her
but actually you praise her
but you trash the institution which she
has been ahead of i mean
well i think that's it i think they
probably do in some they probably can't
admit harry probably can't admit it
himself but they probably do resent
uh the queen in some ways because they
seem to resent this institution that
they felt
trapped by i think as i say i think the
reason they praised her it was
disingenuous
was because they know that she's still
very popular and they don't want to mess
with her brand
while they establish their own one
well well rod
megan has got her way she is a celebrity
now there big celebrity
i mean uh she she was a sort of seedless
actress she's now she called a dinner
party in montecito in california tonight
the whole a-list hollywood would go if
they're invited but she's more than just
a celebrity
she's now a cause celebra she's got
joe biden's press officer she's got
hillary clinton she's got
kia starma they're all piling in on her
side
where does it go from here well
i would hope into obscurity but it
doesn't look very much like that at the
moment does it
that's that's the great problem uh
and it's something freddie was saying
and he was saying earlier about the
queen
that actually the reason the queen has
that reputation
is simply because she does the precise
opposite of what megan
and harry do that is why that brand is
strong
and the the question we're getting now
at the moment over here is what should
be done about the royal family the royal
family
should try to adapt it should we've
already got the queen
dressed up as agatha christie going
around the various members of the royal
family to find out
who said the naughty thing about
archie's skin
uh and there's this feeling that we must
somehow modernize the royal family but
you can't
you can't you can't modernize it in the
way they want it to be modernized
it's an archaic institution we could do
away with it
perfectly reasonably i perfectly
reasonably see the argument for that
but what you cannot do is have a royal
family which is stripped of its regality
of its dignity and of its aloofness you
can't have that
freddie the queen clearly hopes that
this can now be resolved behind
closed doors she doesn't want to up the
ante with
a public slang match either from the
royals or from those who work for the
royal family
which would only invite further
retaliation from
harry and uh and megan
can she do that because it's certainly
this is what strikes me
you can see why the royal family does
not want a public slagging match much as
they would like to reply
they can only have this resolved behind
closed doors if harry and megan agree
and of course they now uh seem to live
off the oxygen of
publicity but this is what makes me
think that they
might go along with this take the most
incendiary claim the
the the conversation apparently about
the potential color
of the baby if this is to be resolved in
public rather than behind closed doors
first of all harry and uh bacon will
have to get their stories straight
they didn't have this story straight
with oprah winfrey
meghan markle began by saying it was she
had been
there people had talked to her about it
several times
while she was pregnant then when it got
to harry it turned out no they hadn't
talked to her
it was him once before she was pregnant
and i didn't they would start to have to
name people give the context of it
give back up proper interview
investigation which of course
the queen of america did not give so
maybe they will have an interest there
freddie
in just getting this resolved behind
closed doors now they've had their say
well possibly and and i mean uh the
queen and the royal family might
find some way to bring them back into
royal royal fault i i find that
unlikely i i think
i mean as for the allegations themselves
you know we might find out that
something was said in a relatively
innocent way that turned that then got
turned into something else we just don't
know uh and i find it again slightly
suspicious that they kept the claims so
vague
um because if you do want to sort of set
this ball rolling
you need to be a bit more specific about
what you're saying
yeah where do you think it goes through
from here
freddie i mean i had thought that once
they did the big interview
and they got things off their chest that
that was is going to be as good as it
gets
for them but i i'm not i don't think
that's going to be true anymore this
could be just the start
i think the i mean the royal families
had these sort of episodes before of
course there was diana but there was
also
fergie and i i watched an interview this
week while looking
trying to write my piece about and it
was fergie with oprah
uh and the amazing thing was how similar
the interview was if you take the racial
stuff out
uh it was pretty much the same
conversation and so
the royal family has to have these sort
of periodic
psychodramas to sustain interest
um but i mean
the reason it always comes back it
always survives i suppose it's because
the queen has this
this brand and this sort of perceived
dignity um
my worry for the royal family and i'm
not that worried because i'm not that
much of a monarchist
but it is that once the queen dies
you're then left with the younger
generations who've done nothing but
psychodrama and and tabloid style media
uh for decades now and can the monarchy
still be dignified
once the queen's gone i'm not sure that
it can with the with the crop
that's underneath okay i'll just say i
think andrew
i think you're absolutely right andrew
it's not going to stop and it's not
going to stop for a simple
mercantile reason which is that they
cannot afford to let it stop
that all of the deals which have been
struck
between megan and harry and netflix uh
and oprah and all of their podcasts
they're they're apparently also going to
be doing a situation comedy which
i thought they'd been doing anyway for
the last two years um
so so they're going to do all this stuff
and
all of that is predicated upon the fact
that he
is royal and she is royal and so they
have to be
simultaneously associated with the brand
even if it means knocking that brand all
the time it needs to
they need to keep their names in the in
the in the
in the limelight as being part of a
royal family so i think it will continue
for a long time until everyone gets
bored of it andrew i would guess
i think you may be right it means
freddie finding point of view that those
of us
who wish them no ill but but also have
really no interest in what they have to
say
think of what they have to say is of no
importance and they talk about many
things of which they have no
qualifications to talk
uh about and that it would be best if
they just faded into obscurity
and then they live a comfortable
privileged life and all the rest of it
that's fine we don't care about that but
we don't want to have to read them
all the time uh we're not going to get
our way on that are we ready
rod's right well it will come like
reality tell if they keep
their own productions if archwell that
their creative production company
uh keeps going they'll become a reality
tv program they'll become a a kind of
like a kardashian's crossed with made in
chelsea
and that is thrilling for some people uh
but most of us
will find it pretty boring and ghastly
and the ratings for these kind of
programs in the end
they may peak but in the end they're
always going to decline
they will yes season by season three
it's pretty boring
well uh while we've been on air we
we just see that uh prince william has
broken the
silence this is really quite surprising
almost it seems
as if he's gone against um what the
queen would wish
prince william is being reported by
chris ship of
itn we are not we are very much
not a racist family says prison prince
william
he broke the royal family silence on the
interview
to his brother harry says i haven't
spoken to him yet but i will do
that's just broken let's finish off by
getting your reaction to that
from both of you you first wrote uh
i suspect that of all the members of the
royal family who sat down to watch that
uh ludicrous non-interview uh i rather
we should have been you doing it andrew
i have to say but there we are
i think the the two people who
undoubtedly hurt the most
were william and kate
and i think my suspicion is that
i mean i know very little about the
royal family's uh internal workings but
my suspicion is that
that william and kate felt particularly
strongly
and were probably more inclined to say
something now
than any of the other members of the
family because most of those barbs
seem directed straight at kate and
william
and that's the story which the press has
had for the last
uh four or five years the question is to
how much it matters you know i saw an
opinion poll there was one in the daily
mail
and there was another opinion poll done
by yougov uh
i think in a way this turmoil which has
been caused
does not remotely reflect the views of
the people in the country
the vast majority of people in the
country have had enough
of harry and megan and rather like the
queen and that that comes out in two
opinion polls carried out on the same
day i don't think it plays i don't think
they play at all well
in in in the united kingdom and perhaps
the royal family ought to be minded
not to say too much just to let them get
on with it because
by and large we're all with them ready
quick final word from you
well it's interesting with william isn't
it because although i'm sure it's very
difficult his falling out with his
brother and all that but
as far as sort of branding goes and and
william and kate are as interested in
branding as harry and megan in their way
they've been rather successful in been
presenting themselves as as the the
decent
uh dignified ones compared to the to the
wild
harry and megan i mean do you remember
when they did that
slightly ostensious uh or it seemed to
be ostentatious they flew ryanair and
had themselves photographed flying
ryanair
uh just a few days after harry and megan
uh had got in trouble for taking private
jets while boring on about climate
change
i i mean it is pr wars now and it's it's
pr wars between a younger generation
uh i think it's going to get very ugly
um and
uh i'm not sure it's very good for the
the institution of the monarchy
we're probably not gives us something to
write about though and talk about
oh yeah we're not complaining
[Music]
you